Canada and the United States have the world’s most straightforward and perhaps the most boring border
However, if you study it carefully, you will find that they are actually very strange.
Although the two sister countries are friendly, they all want to divide the boundaries clearly.
In order to figure out who owns which side of North America, they made a 20-foot wide along the border.
Space, total length 5,500 miles
In addition to the unique New England town built before the demarcation of the border or
Outside the airport that needs to extend the runway, this space has become a "contactless zone" for two countries.
They still take the matter of dividing the boundary very seriously.
Although this "no-contact zone" runs through the wilderness of the Alaska/Yukon area for hundreds of miles.
Sorry, the trees blocking the border ==
You may think that the US-Canada border is definitely the longest and straightest logging area in the world.
However, this is not the case. Logging area? Correct! The most straight? Big mistake!
When you look at the map, it may be straight, and the treaty between the two parties is "speaking" is straight.
However, in reality, this officially established border is actually up to 900 apart.
Hundreds of feet of "Zigzag" horizontal lines are linked together
Where does this come from? Think about North America in the 1800s
The latitude 49 degree line has just been formulated as a national border. It is your job to achieve it.
They gave you a compass and a rope ball, then called you
After delineating three-thirds of North America. Ignore those
Unknown wildlife, your responsibility is just to keep this line straight
That's right
I wish you
good luck
Those surveyors have done their best to build more than 900 national borders.
The straightness of these monuments is almost the same as the border you imagined in a year without GPS.
But that's not a spherical/planar cross that brings mathematicians joy.
Despite this, these borders have been "connected" through contactless areas.
Determined the border between the two countries
Hey, although there are only about 900 national borders here in North America. There is an agreement on the entire US-Canada border.
8000 national borders to draft the borders of the two countries
Despite the size of the plan, Canada and the United States still have controversy
In the dispute between the two countries, there are several Atlantic islands in the United States.
It belongs to Maine, and Canada says it belongs to New Brunswick. Canada (assuming the island is her)
Just a lighthouse on the island, and the United States (assuming the island is her)
Just when the lighthouse is transparent
This issue is not important because it is mainly about the problem between the bird watcher and the fisherman who wants to catch the lobster.
But still hope that this problem can be
Someone solved it before finding the oil under the lighthouse.
Even in non-controversial areas, there are still a few strange places.
For example, this protruding place is more weird when zoomed in.
It does not straddle, but cuts a part of Canada and goes south in the lake.
Then go straight south to the north latitude 49 degrees
This area is home to about 100 Americans and is also a
The best example of the birth of irregular borders
Back in 1783, the victorious Americans were negotiating with the British who controlled British North America (Canada).
They need a map, and this is the best map at the time.
The east coast is indeed very accurate, but the more you go west, the simpler it is.
They were negotiating (now Minnesota and Manitoba). Unfortunately,
That piece of land is hidden under the map illustration, so those American and British 佬
In fact, it is just dividing the gap, (I said really)
They guess that the borders between the two countries should start from the northwest of the lake and extend to the west.
Somewhere until the intersection with the Mississippi River
But somewhere, it became nowhere. Because the omnipotent Mississippi River was broken before the cross.
So the blank border is left until the second round of negotiations 35 years later.
Formulated the aforementioned 49 degrees north latitude
But there is still a problem. The lake we just mentioned is actually more north than they imagined.
More irregular. The northwest point of the lake is here, so the national border needs to jump up.
Convergence it, then immediately fall straight to 49 degrees north latitude, unnaturally cut a part
Canada, continue to go west to the rest of the land
Summary, you can't draw a straight line of hundreds of miles without
Make a few troubles
Vancouver Island: One of the places that was lucky to save, north latitude 49
It should have cut it in half, but both sides agree that it makes no sense.
So choose to circumvent
But the Roberts point next to Vancouver Island was not discovered at the time, so
It is crossed by national borders. This is a very nice town with more than 1000 American citizens.
But there is only one small country, so the older children need to cross the border four times a day.
Go to their own state to go to school
On the east coast, on the contrary, on the island of Canada (Ile Campobello)
The bridge to the United States is her only departure from the island.
However, these two places are not the only ones.
Under satellite photos, you can easily see that there are more places in the contactless area with the same problem.
Whether it is uninhabited, the middle of the lake
It is still a ridiculous place, and the borders of the sister countries of the United States and Canada must remain clear forever.